[Music]
chuck we're back
yes i got a good one got a good one
really constellation names we haven't
ever talked about that we have never
talked about constantly never that we
need some explaining there i just they
need some explaining uh there's like
freaking 30 of them well no no let's fix
this nip it in the bud okay there's more
than 30 constellations oh i'm sure there
are i was just you know there's i don't
even know
how would you pull 30 out of your ass no
i was just i was no you know how you
just make it
you make a uh you just pull a number
like you know i don't know how many
constellations there are i'll tell you
and you'll never forget okay go ahead um
how many keys are on a piano
88 that's how many constellations there
are oh wow cool now you'll never forget
now you'll never forget there are 88
constellations exactly and my favorite
is hercules hercules i'll get to him in
a minute
that's all i really wanted to do
hercules is not my favorite
constellation i just wanted to go
okay i'm sorry somebody watches too many
movies
yeah yeah
so
the thing is the 88 keys in a piano make
music
88 constellations make a zoo
a complete
crazy zoo
a zoo
okay and
they're 88 of them so uh let me start
out with the most famous twelves
go ahead which are like which would they
be let me just let me let me just take a
stab at this
try try this joke there's 12 of them oh
my god
like would one of them be able to date
me
because
like one of those constellations like
totally match up with my personality
so
um yeah so there's the twelve of the
zodiac right and the first three letters
of the word zodiac spell what zoo zoo so
zoo it's it's a panoply of animals
creatures
uh people this sort of thing and there's
12 of them
and so it's what i like is that the sky
has constellations that are of things
that are not even real right there's
like sagittarius is like it's a centaur
right and you know tetris is half
man half horse right right and just to
clarify it's the front half that's the
man and the back end that's the horse if
that were reversed that would be kind of
weird right yeah that'd be bojack
horseman it would be paul jack worse
like the front half is the horse and
he's got a human butt right
actually i have a cameo in bojack
horseman get out i'm totally totally
serious how did i not know this how did
you not know that like season one or two
something like that
it's a cameo yeah it's a fast cameo
that's all that's very cool man
so uh but yeah there are no half front
horses and and so we have we do have
other ones where humans are the rear end
and the animal is the front end but
they're not a constellation like the
minotaur minotaur yeah yeah full head
bullhead human body and a human buttocks
right right um so so however there are
many humans that are indeed a horse's
ass
that's different
all right
so
uh so some are mythical magical
creatures we have a flying horse which
is what pegasus pegasus is up there and
so it's fun to just see
where and when these constellations
started
and what legends what cultures what
mythologies put them on the sky and it's
not the same around the world okay if
you go to
australia
the aborigines who've been in australia
longer than anybody else have been
anywhere practically they have their own
legends and their own things they say is
up there in the sky like there's the
constellation didgeridoo
that's famous aboriginal constellation
and that other constellation boomerang
[Laughter]
boomerang major boomerang minor
we've got the big and the little
boomerang right right not to mention
instead of canis major and minor you
have dingo major
so so the thing is the constellations
tend to emanate from people's cultures
what's especially interesting in
australia is that the milky way which is
in full view most of the year at night
there are parts of the milky way that
are dark
and astrophysically we thought that was
the absence of stars so we thought that
these were gaps
in where the stars were in the milky way
we would later learn that they're simply
dark gas clouds obscuring the view
behind it
so we in the west tend to give meaning
to where we see light
whereas in australia
they saw those dark areas and they gave
meaning to the dark areas
so in fact one of the more famous of the
dark constellations if we may call it
that is what's called dark emu
emu is you know one of the creatures
unique to
australia it's also a a very popular
insurance salesperson here in america
yes it is okay
yes i forgot that was it
yeah so
so emus i i stood up close to one one
time it looks prehistoric i mean you
look at the it's got these three things
for its two feet and all i could think
of was like t-rex's yeah uh
you know it's it's really creepy
prehistoric looking but it's living with
us in modern times anyhow so depending
where you are in the world they have
different constellations and different
cultures and the like that's i just want
to make put that up up front what we
know in the west is what the west has
written about constellations and that's
what i'll spend most of this the rest of
the few minutes on so
so what do we have uh we have sleepless
possibly drug-induced
greeks and romans
and babylonians looking up into the
night sky
okay
i don't know what they were smoking i
don't know right but to see
four stars in the night sky
there's like a triangle and then another
star that's above it to look at that and
say yes i see a crab with two claws
that takes extreme imagination
or drugs
back then they called it pharmakia
that's what the tweets called it because
they were getting hot
[Laughter]
okay all right so so that that's just an
example
of
what
the foundation was for people then
dreaming this stuff up and so most of
the constellations that we see in the
northern hemisphere were seen by the
greeks and the romans and earlier before
them the babylonians and and so they
thought about it and they put up their
legends
okay
so we have perseus and andromeda and and
and and pegasus and there's even medusa
not a constellation but medusa's bloody
severed head is being held by perseus in
the sky
after it had been cut off why did he cut
off medusa's head to uh to turn the
kraken into stone yes
so that he could save
uh
what's her face yes
to save what's her face what's her face
from the kraken and and
pegasus was made from sea foam and it's
a flying horse not anatomically correct
flying horse because in the real world
you any
mammal that flies
it forfeits its front limbs to be wings
to do so that makes sense and bats of
course gave that up in in um game of
thrones the
uh the dragon is a reptile not a mammal
but it's a vertebrate and so if you're
vertebrate you got to give up your four
limbs that dragon gave up its four limbs
for wings it didn't it wasn't four legs
and then wings on top of it all right
and you know who else did it right it
was in the the the smoke smog it's not
small legend of smoke
from
uh the lord of the rings
series that dragon as portrayed in the
film uh its four limbs were it was the
voice of of of whose voice was that
sean connery
okay
it was better the cumberbatch
yes best voice ever for a dragon okay
so there it was sort of inching along on
its elbows basically or which is foreign
i never thought of i did not know this
fact that you're putting out now but
you're right people who do it correctly
they should like the wings become
the
you know the
walking limbs right exactly correct and
all birds don't have front legs right
they don't have they just have the two
legs and they're two wings so so that's
just how that goes wow pegasus in the
sky is not anatomically correct that's
all i'm saying okay however are we
really not going to suspend disbelief
for a flying horse
correct so i'm not going to blame
anybody for giving pegasus four legs
plus wings all right they want them that
way fine but but what else is in the sky
um there's a unicorn right there's
uh you know what it's called it's called
monocerous
okay okay uh i know
yeah exactly yeah so so we have a
unicorn we have a flying horse oh by the
way
again
from the northern hemisphere the horse
is upside down and there's only half
drawn because you don't have enough
stars to fill them out the rest of them
so it's an upside down half white horse
this is the cost of dealing with the
stars you're dealt with okay
better known as glue
this is just it's a pastiche
[Laughter]
i would say there's five out of the 88
that look like what they're supposed to
look like and i'll give this my top list
here so orion the hunter
good to go maybe i'll give you hercules
but orion is a way better strong man in
the sky
than is hercules
uh leo there's some stars that look like
the
the the main the mane and the head and a
body that comes backwards i'll give you
leo so what are we up to three okay i
got one for you you ready go ahead um
there's
a constellation called
triangulum
okay
guess how many stars it has it better
have three it's three stars
it is a most excellent representation of
what it's supposed to be that's pretty
awesome
all right now how did a triangle slip in
with all these mythical magical
creatures it's because
the greeks couldn't see the southern
hemisphere sky
and it wasn't until the 1700s where abby
louis
nicolas lacai i think i have most of his
names right
he was a
he was a peripatetic i think he was a
monk actually but he went to the
southern hemisphere with the purpose
sole intent of mapping the rest of the
sky
oh wow look at that yeah i know i know
so he so for the for the folks in the
west because of course in australia
they've been there done that
millennia earlier okay so so here he is
and
he's this is like late 1700s or so this
is the dawn of the industrial revolution
and he says to myself
these other things are important to me
not the greek and roman gods
so he lays it out and he names
a sextant
oh god that is a that is a consolation
called sexton's it's a yes an octant
okay which preceded the sextant two
navigational devices are down there
right he has argo novice which is the
the ship for uh i think was jason and
the argonauts okay but so that's legend
of course but he has parts of the ship
he has a keel a mast a compass
this is a navigational compass all of
these are constellations there is the
two star constellation
telescopium okay
we're stretching buddy
at 0.8.8 oh it's a telescope
what are you gonna do
wait did he have a one star
constellation called coal
no
this is constantly called the
dot exactly
so if you look in this if you uh there's
also a drafting table
okay
it's yeah it's called picture i think it
is it's it's someone at a drafting table
so the constellations are very different
depending on what era people absorb them
name them and put them in the books
so i'm just fascinated by that i'm
familiar no that is fascinating because
it shows you
that there is indeed a
a psychological and cultural influence
on observation yes
yes yes and what you think and what
matters to you to you yes
yes oh by the way pegasus is a big
square
a big empty square and that's the body
of the horse
but really if you look at other stars in
the area and if i didn't know anything
about flying horses and i'm american
i'd say
damn that looks like a baseball diamond
nice
there you go so if yeah if america were
around 2000 years ago and we had
baseball and we were in charge the name
of the constellations we would have
baseball in the sky right and
constellation apple pie and
constellations chevrolet chevy at the
levee and then we're good to left
so chuck i have way more about
constellations to type we're gonna have
to like spill this into another
explainer cool one day okay because i've
only just begun well this was fun that's
been an explainer on constellations part
one uh come back for part two whenever
we record that i don't know but it'll be
there i promise eventually all right
chuck always good to have you always a
pleasure all right neil degrasse tyson
keep looking up
[Music]
you